this is the reent interview with Nick
[Applause]
kesie thank you all thank you so much uh
for coming out tonight at the blue
building this is a live reason speakes
event in New York and tonight we are
more specifically I am talking to
Jennifer Burns a historian whose new
book is Milton Freedman the last
conservative please give a warm welcome
to Jennifer
Burns thank you thank you New York I'm
GNA do all my talks in New York this is
so awesome thanks for coming out it is
uh oddly a city that Milton Freeman
really didn't hang out in all that much
right he was missing out uh Chicago
Chicago is what it's not even the Second
City anymore it's the third City and
then he went to San Francisco even
further down the list you know he did
spend time in New York actually it's a
little known fact we all think of him as
a Chicago School Economist his PhD is
actually from Colombia Colombia is
practically
Connecticut all right no point well
taken and he and he worked here a bit
before and after World War II we'll
probably get yeah he had a whole East
Coast life he had a a New York world he
spent time in Vermont New Hampshire and
of course he was forged in the Steely
cauldron of New Jersey that's right
Suburban New Jersey Only the Strong
surviv the greatest state in in all the
union um let's start by talking about uh
why uh why Milton freedan why did you
write a biography of Milton Freeman so
um it wasn't part of a plan it really
grew out of my first book which was a
biography of a Rand and once the godess
godd of the market IR Rand and the
American right another person who had a
real New York history although she loved
New York more than than fredman so um
you know I finished that project I
didn't really know what I was going to
do next and I was doing a variety of
different um inquiries I was looking
into kind of a concept history of the
idea of neoliberalism was the sort of
first moment this was a buzzword what is
neoliberalism I was thinking of writing
a broader synthetic history of
conservatism conservative ideas I felt
like I had maybe a third of the story
based on Ein Rand and the research I had
done and I was thinking of Rand as
really a bottom up figure you know
nobody anointed her nobody said read her
listen to her actually they all said the
opposite yet she found her people she
found her audience so fredman I thought
it was very different kind of top down
Elite credentialed and eventually I
realized whichever one of these projects
I did I had to wrestle with Milton
fredman and so once I started to do that
I kind of had the biographical itch
again oh 5 foot one of him right
you um what what is it about you know
what's the essence of fredman for you um
you know what if if you have to sum up
his life or you know what he inspires in
you uh what is it so um I think fredman
is a really is the best example of
thinking about how Market principles and
ideas can be taken outside of the field
of economics and applied more broadly I
think he probably does that more broadly
than I would but nonetheless I think he
shows that real power of sort of
abstract thought and Analysis and the
way that um once you take something out
of the context the intellectual context
in which it grows it can have all kinds
of you know unintended consequences and
can also be very powerful where did that
come from I mean he grew up he was was
he the child of immigrants or the
grandchild of immigrants he was the
child of immigrants so um his and he's
growing up Jewish in mostly in rawe or
near newers so he grew up uh Jewish in
rawe New Jersey so small town America
very different than most Jewish
immigrants they landed in New York they
landed in Chicago they had a really
Urban um more collective experience and
and lived in these Jewish ethnic
communities and he had uh there were
about 10 Jewish families in raway New
Jersey so he's really immersed in that
kind of broader anglo-protestant
culture and I would say his parents were
successful but they weren't exceptional
in any way that would make you think
sort of they would you know give birth
to Milton Friedman although I have to
say he had three older sisters and as I
was looking through their High School
records I realized one of his sisters
was actually ranked higher than him and
like won more Awards so it's clearly a
very distinguished family um and I think
that there was this kind of drive to
know the world to explain it and it got
really supercharged by the experience of
the Great Depression I think without the
Great Depression he may have been more
focused on mathematics or kind of a more
technical field but he came to believe
it was just one like why are people so
poor like what just happened you know
this is he graduates in from college in
1932 and that's what really changes his
Focus to economics and then we have to
understand the 1930s as well there's
this huge economic crisis in the United
States it's not just in the United
States it's enveloping all of Europe
there's also the rise of totalitarian
governments there's the rise of
murderous anti-Semitism there's all
these crises in the world so it is a
time to go back to what are the first
principles what are the fundamentals
what are the ideas we need to get
ourselves out of this predicament can
you he undergrad he went to Ruckers and
he encountered a couple people there who
kind of shaped his life then he went to
Chicago is that right and then Colombia
as well got his PhD can you walk through
you know a lot of people in his
situation going to college and you know
during or graduating into the depression
would have been like well what we need
is an antidote to capitalism capitalism
has failed he took a very different
lesson from that that really from the
beginning put him at odds with the kind
of consensus who were the people who
helped him develop you know a a
countercultural set of ideas yeah so um
it rers it he actually his first
economics class he didn't even like
think was interesting at all um he
doesn't mention it all it's on his
transcript he doesn't mention it at all
he became inspired to go into the field
by Arthur Burns who becomes this like
lifelong relationship and Homer Jones
and they both pointed him to Chicago
what's really distinctive about Chicago
and I didn't didn't know this when I
began the research I thought I would get
to Chicago you know I'm going through
the archives I'm trying to understand
what is the intellectual world into
which Milton Freeman landed and I
thought it was going to be Les a fair
economics like this is a market
correction it'll eventually solve itself
and I found something very different I
found his professors um banding together
and they created something called the
Chicago plan which called for very
significant interventions in the banking
system um it called for really elaborate
Federal relief or very substantive
Federal relief about I don't know 90% of
the Chicago plan is eventually enacted
in the 1935 Banking Act but if they had
had their way they would have gone even
further they had the pet idea of 100%
money which basically means no
fractional Reser fractional Reserve
banking they would have completely
revolutionized the banking system and so
these are Freeman's professors and I was
like wait a second am I not studying The
Chicago School of Economics so I really
had to kind of reset and think what's
going on here so so to answer that
question what did fredman get he got a
set of ideas about the importance of
markets the importance of limited
government the the importance of what
they call liberalism at the time yet
they also got people who were very
committed to responding to the social
conditions and the economic crisis
around him so from the beginning he
thought of these ideas as very Dynamic
and is tied to political advocacy and
political change so that's like one
piece of the puzzle the other is that he
was immersed in the Chicago tradition of
monetary
economics and so the monetary
perspective again pointed to Banks it
pointed to the financial system and it
gave you a way to think of about kind of
aggregate economic activity that
sometimes we think well that really only
happened with keynesianism but if you're
thinking about money you're thinking
more systemically so he had an
explanation that was basically we have
problems we have a liquidity crisis we
have problems in the banking sector we
know what this is as he'll later argue
we have some institutions that have made
it worse but it's not like a phase
transition in the economy it's not a
sign of secular
stagnation um so so he had it he had
another
explanation and what's interesting is
that the economists that were like maybe
just two to three years older than him
who became the the really the sort of
lions of liberal economics and of
Keynesian economics they got there just
a little bit later when the new
explanation on the ground was
keynesianism so fredman was just that
little bit older where he came in he got
the monetary explanation and that was
really all he needed can you explain
briefly what his read on the Depression
was so it it wasn't that cap capitalism
was broken it needs to be replaced
wholesale it's that you know something
has gummed up the machine yeah so what
was that so it's interesting because
he's I can see from his notes and his
thinking that he already has this idea
that inflation is a monetary phenomenon
in the 1940s I mean I I see him writing
this this you know famous statement he
makes in the 70s we associate with the
70s he's got it very early but he's
still trying to work out like what does
it look like and so that will be the
basis of the book he writes With Honor
Schwarz and so that's another New York
connection because Schwarz is here
toiling away the National Bureau of
economic research um and doing most of
the research and the analysis and they
will eventually come up with this
broader framework of
monitorisation is this reinterpretation
of the Great Depression and they they
have a chapter where they call it the
great
contraction and so the idea they argue
is they put together all these figures
of Schwarz has literally gone to the
vaults and gone to the books and when
she can't find the numbers she like
pesters the bankers like help me get the
numbers and adds it all up and they
setep back and they say uh we lost
onethird of the money in circulation
during the Great Depression that's why
it was so bad the the money was
destroyed as the banks went under yeah
where did it go it disappeared because
infraction Reserve banking the bank
takes your deposit and then it creates
more money by lending against that and
and as we've seen from recent bank runs
it works because of trust because
everyone doesn't want their money all at
once if you want your money all at once
it's not there it's like a weird kind of
psychological you have to you have to
trust just at the moment when you're
least likely to trust and this is
there's the famous scene and It's a
Wonderful Life which I think is from
1939 or there or no maybe a little bit
later um but where there's a
bankrupt yeah and the the so we have to
remember the 's no FDIC and this is one
of the reforms that comes in in 1935 and
it's the type of thing his professors
are calling for because it really
fundamentally undermines trust in the
system if you work hard save your money
put it in a bank and then it disappears
I mean that that's just devastating so
so he believes that this is a systemwide
crisis and he in short start homing in
on the Federal Reserve which is created
I think it goes into operation in 1914
so so it's new it's not that um it's not
that established of an institution and
they say wait a second the Federal
Reserve System was created for this
problem to support Banks to intervene in
a liquidity crisis it didn't do that so
it stepped back and it just watched it
happen so it turns out that the people
that I thought were the Chicago
economists who would say oh just let the
market go down it'll correct itself
it'll come back up those people at the
FED they weren't professors of Economics
but that was a very basic approach in a
banking world you know it's oh it's a
correction and we shouldn't it would be
moral hazard they didn't use the term
moral hazard but it would be um it would
be wrong to help out a bank that's weak
because that's its own fault um you know
the insight has to do with the the money
supply and that the fed or you know that
money disappeared and the FED contracted
the money supply at the time they should
have been loosening things up there's
that inside but then there's also the
method that um uh that fredman and Anna
Schwarz focused on which really was
empirical how odd was that for an
economist to be really you know looking
at facts rather than Theory so one
reason you know the empirical stuff was
out of fashion was because Anna Schwarz
was doing it right they they wouldn't
have let her do anything that was
particularly Cutting Edge it was like
okay fine you can go add up these
numbers and this actually comes out of
fredman's first series of jobs he he got
his first jobs on the federal government
during the New Deal when there was a
great effort to measure um both the
crisis and the programs and just the
general population like okay if we have
a consumption problem people can't buy
what they need how much do they need how
much do they typically make and so the
New Deal agencies were you know doing
this type of work but this was not what
professional economists were doing
especially after World War II they
moveed much more to math mathematical
techniques General equilibrium models
bigger partial equilibrium models just
just models and abstractions that would
show you how the whole fits together and
they would be feeding in a few variables
like the interest rate or the federal
budget or the multiplier the Canan
multiplier and it meanwhile fredman was
because he had this connection to this
women's world of consumption economics
like immersed in this data and so um it
was terribly unfashionable money was
terribly unfashionable which is like
such a strange thing to say but because
of the experience of the Great
Depression people believe that the the
Federal Reserve was really powerless and
so Freeman and Schwarz end up arguing it
could have done yes it was powerless but
that was because it made mistakes not
because it lacked power not because
money was a meaningless Veil over more
important forces um to focus a little
bit on that issue of consumption fredman
in a interesting way was kind of doing
Woman's Work right where consumption was
some this was home economics like what
did people buy Etc and Anna Schwarz is
part of that as well as his wife Rose uh
director was her maiden name and she had
a masters in economics and she also
worked in similar Fields um what what
what was gained by looking at
consumption data rather than these Grand
theories so yeah I'll say this is
another thing I didn't expect to find
was the number of women who worked
closely with fredman who collaborated
with him formally or informally in all
of his major Publications and basically
all of his major scientific work I was
very surprised to find that and I think
what that did is it brought in this just
set of of really empirical data and
understanding kind of how people made
spending decisions that you could lose
track of um if you were taking the more
theoretical approach which seemed more
important so one of the
kind of outputs of this is a theory of
the consumption function um in which
fredman ends up arguing for the theory
of permanent income which is still a
concept that economists use today and
that came out of these women that he
knew they were mostly friends of roses
and they were studying um farm income
and this was Dorothy Brady Rose's best
friend and Margaret Reed who would
eventually become Chicago's only woman
Professor tenur woman professor in that
era and they were trying to figure out
like you know a farmer if you buy a fact
a tractor you spend a lot of money this
year but you don't spend that the other
year or if you have a really good
harvest you get a so how would you make
sense of these ups and downs and so they
ended up and then looking at what um
Farmers actually did ended up concluding
they they sort of naturally smoothed it
they they anticipated what their
permanent income would be over the
course of their life they kind of smooth
it out and now this was important
because it ended up really putting
pressure on the idea of the Keynesian
consumption function which had a very um
had this idea there was a very clear
relationship between consumption income
and consumption and if you had that very
clear relationship you could measure the
multiplier you could understand the
impact of a stimulus program um you
could design more stimulus programs and
what fredman's immersion in the data
showed and and really these women kind
of brought this finding to him and he
theorized it was that's not really true
like it depend there's many other
factors at work that predict how much
people will spend their money so it just
it clouded this the Keynesian Paradigm
that had been very clear-cut previous to
that he um one of his early very
influential essays talked about
economics as a positive science and it's
can you explain that and was that almost
a uniquely American response to kind of
European Theory I mean is it pragmatics
or empiricism versus
yeah this is the methodology of positive
economics which you know sometimes gets
analyzed in terms of the the basic gist
is what is the test of a theory a theory
is only good in so far as it predicts
what will happen in the real world and
so you can this does come out of
conversations with Carl popper um it's
it's been taken up as a kind of
methodology of science or in these uh uh
debates on the history of science what I
discovered is it was actually incubated
in fredman's battle with the Kohl's
commission which was a group of European
igrs many trained in physics or math who
were um in the Kohl's foundation for
economic research at University of
Chicago and this was basically a
parallel economics department and they
they kind of had join appointments and
they were the modelers and they were
also very much politically left didn't
have to necessarily be the case so there
there's some lineup between doing a
model that tells you what the policy
should be and endorsing an activist
policy anyhow Freeman just didn't like
these guys at all and they believe me
did not like him um they were just like
you know uh oil and water so these guys
were more on the left Freeman was more
conservative they wanted to do these big
models fredman was like very suspicious
of that and what made it really
difficult was that Freedman was very
talented as a mathematician and actually
had written several really important
papers in statistic iCal economics so
they sort of knew he could do what they
were doing and he was choosing not to
let me go back to that essay that essay
if you read it in light of this conflict
with Kohl's is a methodological argument
against abstraction in economics was
that
influential uh yes over time it was and
I think it actually I found some
economists talking like in the 80s and
90s and they would they would kind of
simp simplify it to well assumptions
don't matter all it matters is that we
can predict Freedman improved
assumptions don't matter um and that's
really not what he was the the the
overall message I think it was more
about you have to test your theories
against empirical data from The Real
World but what he was able to say is
that sometimes you make very unrealistic
assumptions so one would be this
Assumption of rationality doesn't matter
if you think it's unrealistic that
people individually are rational it
matters if you come combine them all and
you look from 30,000 fet up at the
aggregate they act as if they're
rational and that's enough to go on so
it has been hugely influential but maybe
in it's been interpreted in its own set
of ways uh let's before we go on to some
of his other insights and kind of policy
positions or thoughts that really had
major influence on you know the world
we're living in now let's talk a little
bit more about
monitorisation as kind of simply put as
possible uh I could do it in two words
Money Matters just the name of one of
his last major book yeah money Mischief
than uh so Money Matters goes back to
this idea that money is not a veil it it
has active force in the economy um and
so that just became kind of his push for
um looking at looking at money his Ally
and in the moment but it also monetarism
grows up in opposition to keynesianism
and so the idea being what is the what
is the way to underwrite economic growth
with in the Keynesian synthesis economic
growth requires a more activist federal
government and it specifically requires
the taxing and spending powers of the
federal government to be strategically
deployed to enhance economic growth and
monetarism is an alternative that says
no economic growth comes from private
economic actors um who will generate
plenty of um ideas initiatives
Innovations if left alone but they need
a steady monetary environment if you if
the price level goes up and down or
fluctuates too much those private
economic actors retrench they hold their
money they don't know how to make
investments or plan and ultimately
inflation which is the big volatility
and all of this is always and everywhere
a
monetary not it's not about taxation or
you know government program a wage price
spiral or uh Monopoly and so um yeah
that that becomes an essential part of
the story and then in the 60s and
especially the 70s
monitorisation of what's going on can
you talk a little bit about how how what
started to happen in the late 60s and
the 70s couldn't be explained very well
by kind of Keynesian or or consensus
economics and people were looking for an
alternative explanation which he seemed
to provide yeah so let me say two things
the other core of monetarism besides
money matters is what Freeman called
like the K percent rule that you should
pick a percentage and he said 4% and
that's what the the money supply should
grow at this 4% R and then that would
provide enough room for the economy to
grow but people would know this is sort
of what I can count on but also that
it's it's set right it's kind of like
it's a rule it's very important and
that's another piece of the Chicago
tradition rules over discretion we can
also think about this is almost a
hayekian idea that you create the
framework for competition the rule of
law stable institutions and then you let
kind of activity unfold not men right
yeah so it's all it it all it all really
kind of has a philosophical symmetry
under the surface so the other thing
that's challenging though is they call
it the Paradox of monetary policy when
it's done right you don't notice it it's
only when it's done wrong that you
notice it so it's sort of it's it's a
hard thing to get anyone to care about
because you don't get a you know if
you're a politician you have a good
monetary policy nobody really notices
they do notice when you have a bad
monetary policy so if Freeman first made
his name analyzing def
which was the great contraction you know
he really has a the the the the move
into more influence is in inflation the
kind of flip side and so you know
throughout the 60s as I said he's really
hated by like the Kennedy Council of
economic advisers they're just like oh
with this guy Freedman like go away like
shut up and go away because you know
they have a tax cutter they have a
stimulus and they're like oh the economy
is responding really well and Freeman
will pop up in Congress and say oh yeah
yes that was that monetary expansion um
that then with a long and variable lag
has led to an economic expansion and
they're like you know there's a quote
from Walter heler he's like so what
we're just playing fiscal titly Winks in
Washington they feel very diminished by
fredman so at any rate in 1960 but they
they could ignore him too because one of
the things you point out which is really
hard to kind of understand that after
World War II there was generally you
know the economy was in pretty good
shape there was steady growth not too
much unemployment not too much inflation
things were stable so then fredman is
constantly carping about money and it's
kind of like why don't you just shut up
exactly like what you know he seems like
a doomsayer sort of like a prophet
without uh without honor so but
eventually this Doom saying comes to
seem really relevant so in in 1967 he
makes this famous speech at the American
economic Association and he this sort of
idea previously is like we don't really
need to worry about inflation um and
even inflation can be good because a
little bit of a price rise means like
things are really humming and generally
there'll be lower unemployment when
there's a little bit more inflation and
so it's kind of a trade-off and fredman
says you know this trade-off it might
work in the short run but it's not going
to work in the long run because it's
theoretically possible and he goes on to
explain how that you have a rising price
level and then eventually you have
Rising unemployment because of all the
ill effects of inflation and uncertainty
and so and then he's then he looks at
the monetary data and says you know it's
in front of you know 200 500 economists
um based on what the FED has been doing
we're going to be heading into an
inflationary period so he just like
makes this prediction and you everyone
thinks it's novel it's arresting here's
this provoca turb they don't agree with
it and then in the early 1970s because
of the combination of Vietnam War
spending social spending and a very
loose monetary policy that inflation
starts to emerge and so you have these
economists who were kind of they have
their models and they're running the
numbers and they're saying oh Freeman's
wrong oh Freeman's wrong and they're
like well he could be a little bit right
and eventually they're like by gum he's
right and it really um that long run
that trade-off disappears over the long
run as he said in this more inflationary
environment can you uh in the book you
do a fantastic job of painting the
various characters and you've mentioned
Arthur Burns who at this point was
fredman's professor and friend and then
became the head of the Federal Reserve
under Richard Nixon um and they come to
a kind of dead end right um can you talk
a little bit about that and what does
that say about the way fredman kind of
operates intellectually and politically
so um I guess I'll start by saying I'm
not related to Arthur
Burns and I would say Arthur Burns is
not um just a professor he's not just a
friend he is the sort of model of of how
to be in the world fredman calls him a
surrogate father so fredman loses his
father in uh I think his senior year of
high school and it's not long after that
he meets Arthur Burns and as we talked
about his family is sort of a typical
immigrant family he doesn't really have
a role model and he sees Arthur Burns
professor at records also from a Jewish
immigrant family and just says wow so
and who has wasp ified himself he's
become fully kind of presentable in
Elite culture yes and he ends up having
especially when their barriers
anti-semitic barriers kind of drop in
World War II ends up you know he advises
Eisenhower he's a professor Columbia you
know he's head of the ne NBR um and
actually a lot of what I know about
fredman and his life and that like one
of the best sources for this book or the
letters he would write to Arthur Burns
because they long letters throughout
every step of his career because they're
close but they're not physically close
and they're also like kind a dear diary
like he just writes like these very
open-ended kind of musings and thoughts
and personal stories to Arthur Burns so
that's like the biographer gold when you
find a correspondence like that um but
then the correspondence really takes
this sharp turn Burns is appointed by
Nixon and everyone thinks oh it's now a
freed manite fed you know they're really
going to be inflation Hawks money
nobody's going to question If Money
Matters and Arthur Burns it turns out
it's not a monist and he doesn't
actually have a ton of really clear
ideas about what the FED should do and
he thinks that inflation is caused you
know by wage price spirals he's not
really sure but he doesn't really have a
strong sense that the FED is responsible
for inflation so he ends up advocating
um for what is called incomes policy
this is wage and price guidelines which
is like the first stage to wage and
price controls which she will also
eventually support and when fredman so
apparently what happens I know from this
letter you know Freedman picks up the
newspaper and he opens it and it says
like Arthur Burns supports incomes
policy and he's like what you know how
can this be and so I quote from some
it's it's a letter it's like the it's
almost like the end of A Love Affair
letter you know he writes this letter to
Burns it's he gets he tries to go to
sleep he can't sleep he like wakes up in
the middle and like Arthur how could you
you know I feel betrayed you know it's
this really intense letter um and then
even before Burns can write back he
sends another one because fredman is the
number one critic of the fed he's like
the Ron Paul of his day you know he's
just always criticizing the fed and all
of a sudden people are like well Mr
Freeman what do you think of what Arthur
Burns has to say and he's like uh oh you
know I have to really say what I think
um and to him it's not an option that he
peric or trim or you know oh Arthur's
fine like it's it's really obvious that
he wouldn't agree with Arthur Burns and
he has to publicly disagree with him
this is very painful and they
resuscitate a friendship of sorts but
it's never the way it was and he's also
by this point uh freein is writing a
Newsweek so he has like a very popular
very public uh Forum in which to bash is
right so he's basically has to sort of
publicly attack his best friend in order
to maintain
his intellectual integrity and his
reputation um so it's not easy uh and
and burns is really not happy and the
letters are quite Frosty it's
interesting the book has some pictures
of Arthur Burns who really is old timey
I mean Milton fredman isn't mod he
didn't become like a you know he wasn't
wearing NE jackets in the 60s but burns
looks like he's stuck in about he always
yeah had a pipe the pipe was a Fed share
thing you got have a pipe at least back
in the day to kind of just close out the
uh story about
[Music]
monitorisation in terms of what became
known as stagflation towards the end of
the 70s um Paul vulker is named to the
FED uh head of the fed and especially
under Reagan he seems to be kind of
doing monitor policy at the FED but he's
a reluctant person and fredman is kind
of critic of him even though he did by
most accounts break the back of
inflation what did vulker do and why was
it or was it not a kind of monitor
solution yeah it's It's Tricky um so
vulker is definitely reading the the
monetarist literature he's aware of the
kind of um Revolution and ideas at
fredman is spearheading and he does
believe like fredman that sort of over
the long run you can't trade-off
inflation and unemployment he absolutely
believes that he and he believes that
this is where they are now that
trade-off has broken down and inflation
has created an environment that's that's
really bad for everyone in the economy
um he's also interested in so fredman's
technical ideas to watch the monetary
Aggregates which are these specific
measures of money that he and Schwarz
have um really sort of devised and
popularized and so vulker announces that
he's now going to Target Aggregates so
this is basically what everyone thought
Arthur Burns would do and vulker announc
he's going to do it now it it turns out
I go into this in some detail in the
book and there's sort of a debate was
vulker kind of playing with Aggregates
because he really wanted to jack up
interest rates I tend to think he was
genuine in thinking Aggregates would
work this was a reasonable assumption to
make at that moment and now it seems
like it's not a reasonable assumption um
because the Aggregates turned out to be
very hard to control and there's
deregulation I don't want to bog down in
all the details but vulker sticks with
it and eventually through the mechanism
of very high interest rates um is able
to reset expectations around inflation
is able to really kind of change um the
economic piece
so the the way that vulker kind of is in
the shadow of Freedman is one in
realizing there is no long run tradeoff
and two I haven't talked about Freeman's
mechanism of inflation but He suggests
that
expectations are a key part of the story
so again this is sometimes loss because
now we're like oh inflationary
expectations like everybody knows this
this is why it's entrenched or
transitory this is like what Freeman
puts on the table it's not that nobody
ever thought about it but he says this
is really the mechanism in which
inflation accelerates once it gets going
and of course the rational expectations
will jump off of this whole field of
Economics will jump off this idea of
expectation so this is one of these
Freeman ideas that it's hard to see
because we just think this is how things
are this is like very natural thing and
but he's really the one who who puts it
forward so all that being said Freeman
and vulker do not like each other at all
it just don't get along vulker is really
tall Freeman's really short you know
vulker is like an establishment guy who
will sort of work for any work for a
republican work for a Democrat and
fredman is like more ideological and you
know really only talks to and works with
Republicans and so um and then fredman
is the academic who knows how his theory
is going to work and vuler is more like
I got to try this I got to try that it's
a complicated world and so the result is
that they it's really hard they no they
won't give each other any credit
whatsoever we do know though that um one
person who did Love Freeman was Ronald
Reagan who is the president when vul's
interest rates are to 20% you know
unemployment is spiking and Ronald
Reagan is getting a very consistent
message from Milton free Freedman which
is stick with it do it now you know this
is 1981 1982 things are going to be
better by 1984 this is going to work and
so in that way Freeman really does have
vulker back in that he's helping to
create the environment where there can
be an independent um you know Federal
Reserve controlling or or affecting the
money supply and it is amazing again you
know we've had inflation and it's with
us uh today but I mean when you look at
how high interest rates were in 1980 81
82 and then they just really drop um did
and did that help um you know did that
the fact that vulker seemed not care so
yeah I mean there's another piece of the
puzzle which is one thing freein was
saying throughout the 60s and the 50s
which made people think he was just
absolutely bat he said interest rates
are not not a good guide to inflation or
rather interest rates are not a good
guide to monetary policy interest rates
don't tell you reliably if money is
tight or money is loose and this was
like saying like the sky isn't blue
because everyone was like of course we
know that we look at the interest rate
to tell if money is tight or money is
loose and he's basically like it's a
lagging indicator so it could actually
because we have a high interest rate
that could mean money was very loose and
he also said eventually um in a high in
an inflationary environment that
relationship is going to break down so
vulker also recognizes this that when
you get inflation going um so prices are
going up all the time and in order to
make any type of profit on your loan
your interest rate has to be higher than
inflation so if inflation is going up
interest rates are also going to go up
so then you actually have this total
breakdown in the mechanism that's
assumed they're assumed to work Contra
you know in in contradiction but now
they're working together and this is
also the concept of nominal and real
interest rates and the other thing
that's really hard to recognize is the
Federal Reserve does not distinguished
between real and nominal interest rates
prior to the vulcar era like they just
don't think about it and almost nobody
else does because there hasn't been
inflation it's been a pretty steady
States and the interest rate is also
regulated and fixed so why would you
think about this relationship so fredman
however has gone with Anna Schwarz all
the way back to 1867 he's just got a
like bigger piece of History to work
with and so um that's another one of
these things that sounds totally crazy
in 1964 and like super smart in
1974 um we are going to go to questions
in a few minutes um let's I'm sure
monitor ISM will come up in the
questions but uh let's talk about some
of the other big impacts that um
Freedman had had um he pioneered the
idea of school vouchers and he also
talked about that in other context but
that seems to be one of his most um kind
of fertile legacies we're living in a
world now where more and more school
districts more and more States uh and
you know local districts are offering
School vouchers what was his plan and
how did that come into being so um a
couple things to say about that one is
I'm pretty sure he got it from John
Stewart Mill because there there's a
throw away line in on Liberty where he
mentions that I know fredman read that
book as a graduate student um and so let
me just prefaces was saying you know
part of the Chicago inheritance is a
belief in markets but also a concern
about inequality and a concern about
when markets don't work and and those
who are are kind of left out and so in
the beginning of his career Freeman's
really advocating policies that are akin
to a universal basic income it's later
reformulated is a negative income tax um
when he comes up with school vouchers I
think this is during capitalism and
freedom when he's kind of doing what I
said at the beginning how can we take
kind of Market Concepts incentives
competition and and take them outside
you know just sort of Commodities
markets maybe or whatever would be the
traditional object of Economics what
happens over time though is fredman
shifts his Focus from
thinking the best solution to poverty
and inequality is UN unversal basic
income he shifts it to focusing on
school choice and in part that's because
the negative income tax is partially
enacted and in part that's because he
really starts to worry about
globalization and he's a huge proponent
of free trade and globalization but a
couple years into it it kind of dawn on
him like the low skilled American worker
is now in a global competition and our
schools are not very good and
additionally where you're born TI ties
you into a school ties you into
opportunity ties you into your life path
and therefore the sort of biggest
Injustice is being born in a place with
a school that's not very good and you
can't afford to go anywhere else so he
and Rose will eventually leave the money
that they have to school choice
foundation so so that really becomes
part of this larger political economy
where you try to think of like what is
the biggest structural problem um in
capitalism and is that not everyone is
able to participate in and compete in
markets on anything like an equal basis
in education he comes to believe is that
I know I interviewed him 50 years after
the essay where he first talked about
school choice and he raps aized about
the raway public schools and I was kind
of like H you know this but um yeah he
he really had a powerful experience
where the schools he went to seemed to
be he thought they were a great
equalizer yeah I think so I mean he felt
like he benefited from that education
and um unfortunately it wasn't available
to everyone I do have to say though just
to be clear he did also dream of a world
in which all education was privatized so
he might rapid IE about the rawe public
school but also Imagine a world where
you know all education was privately
provided yeah um and talk a little bit
about the negative income tax and how
how that you know why he fixated on that
and then why that you know I mean that
became part of the Earned Income Tax
Credit things like that which he was not
so much a fan of yeah so what I
discovered in the archive uh you know um
I read like probably 200 some boxes you
know I just sift through and see what
you're going to find and eventually I
found early on in my research is called
a proposal for a guaranteed minimum
income I found a couple versions of this
and I was sort of like I wonder why
fredman has this paper and I kept
reading and then I was like wait a
second freman wrote this paper you know
and I was like what and so actually it
happened in New York he apparently met
Gunner Myrtle I don't know where or how
somewhere in who shared the Swedish
economists very Lefty shared the Nobel
Prize under complaint or protest with
Friedrich Hayek right and who was very
well known in later years for an
American dilemma this study of American
race relations and so somehow they meet
they get to talking and they decide that
some type of minimum income is this like
great policy so Freeman writes his first
proposal and then when he turns up at
Mont Peller and you know years later
he's also like banging the drum for you
his Universal basic income and basically
the idea he he as he sees it is this is
he calls it compatible with the liberal
Pol because um it would be sort of
counter cyclical you would get it when
when you needed it um and he basically
sees it as giving people a way to get
into markets without compromising their
individual choice and so as opposed to
having and you also have to remember
this is the era of very very intrusive
welfare programs I mean they're still
intrusive in different ways but you know
if the welfare inspector came to your
home and you were an unmarried woman who
had children and you were being
supported and they saw a hat a man's hat
in the house you could lose your benefit
you know so the very kind of snooping
and prying so he envisions this welfare
system in which will just be provided
with cash and you'll make your own
decisions about how to use it and you'll
figure out you know what is a basic
social minimum that people need
so so he's very fond of that idea and he
eventually supports it through decides
it should run through the tax system and
in the 60s is very widely discussed and
he'll make some modifications to say you
know you have to be careful of the
benefits of cliff and maybe you want to
have a work you know reward income more
but he says a lot of the same things
that sort of today's proponents of Ubi
will say um about its potential you know
efficacy he um had an abiding respect
for the little people right like he
really thought that virtually anybody
would you know given some Freedom would
make good choices or better choices than
other people could make in their lives
um where did that come from that's an
interesting question um I mean I think
he's just very optimistic um I think we
also in a way when you kind of step back
you might not think of him as a sort of
like quintessential 60s figure but he
kind of is he's kind of sticking it to
the man you know
he kind of wants everyone to be free fly
their freak flag you know he has some of
that he's very freaky
yeah and he also decides over time you
know he he wants to be a supporter of
capitalism but he doesn't want to have
any kind of social darwinist kind of the
strong make it and the weak Fall by the
wayside so hence his interest in you
know whether it's Ubi or or school
choice but um he needs another grounding
for capitalism and he eventually decides
it's freedom and that's kind of the
central value and so once he latches on
to that it just you know becomes more
and more important right and the first
version of that uh kind of as a big text
is the book he wrote with Rose's uh
assistance capitalism and freedom yes he
sees them as mutually reinforcing and
then later free to choose um it's all
about giving people more ability and not
only to make choices but to actually be
able to participate yeah um talk about
his role in ending the military draft
okay so that's another interesting one
um so again think of like Milton
Friedman is the quintessential 60s
figure he's very much against the draft
and he again sees that as like a
straightforward violation of individual
rights that the state has some type of
ownership claim on you he just
philosophically objects to that very
much in the way that a Rand did he's
very different though from fa hyek and
Von mises who basically are like
coming out of the European experience
sometimes you need an army quick so we
should still keep conscription that's
that's kind of a divide um and so he
does a couple things one is he by this
point is a really big figure in the
culture and so he is able to talk about
ending the draft and he's like a
republican economics professor he's very
respectable so he kind of shifts the
politics away from the kind of hippie
long hair you know um left leaning Vibe
and interestingly Buckley also supports
it and Nixon is again the one who will
push the policy through so it it
actually does have a lot of conservative
support um and then he also will um you
know support this analysis which
basically says the number one argument
against a draft is from the military uh
who like the way things are and who say
it's going to be way too much money this
is how they just basically say we can't
even consider it and so free frean comes
and says look sure you're looking at one
sticker price which is the cost of
paying your soldiers but you're not
looking at the the Unseen cost right the
seen and the Unseen the Unseen cost is
you're taking a huge swath of your you
know men out of the labor force in their
most productive years so he kind of
reorients it to this other metric but he
also makes it about kind of costs and
benefits and there's a moral piece but
that's not really what he leads with now
the other thing
and maybe I'm wrong about this so let me
know if you find it it could not find
Melton Freeman saying anything about the
Vietnam War and his thoughts on the
Vietnam War he managed to lead this
public campaign against the military
draft without commenting on the war and
so this to me was just stupendous um
that he was is that because he didn't
have an opinion which seems hard to
believe or he just it seems hard to
believe I think he just felt like the
most important thing I can do right now
is end the draft and if I Sidetrack into
a debate on the War I will lose like the
message that I have um and you point out
in the book it's deeply uh touching
actually that he relied on an economic a
cost benefit analysis put together by a
Japanese American who had whose family
had been intered in World War II and
that helped end the draft that just is a
beautiful kind of symmetry yeah one of
his students Walter oi yeah um and it's
also aing aming how quickly the draft
ramped up during the 60s from several
thousand a year to 400,000 uh a year I
think in 1966 you point out so this is
gigantic um let's talk about Chile
before we go to uh to well one more
question but Chile why um why is uh
Milton Freeman tied so tightly with the
pinet regime which was a repressive uh
tyrannical regime that ultimately
you know uh after that period was over
Chile was for many years the uh the the
kind of best performing economy in Latin
America but what did fredman do and is
it right to link him to the penet regime
yeah it's an interesting question
because he didn't spend very much time
in Chile so the the kind of story starts
with um United States Government funding
um students to come and study from Chile
at the University of Chicago which was
part of a broader kind of
effort to spread American ideas during
the Cold War and so this group of
students it's eventually about a hundred
is trained at Chicago only one of them
is actually Freeman's doctoral student
but they take classes with him and they
kind of get the whole Chicago um set of
economic ideas and they go back to Chile
and they really um are a minority to say
the least because Chile is following
import substitution industrialization
isi which creates a very large role for
the state and it's protectionist in
order to nurture domestic Industries and
um you know big companies and and the
state are very much intertwined and the
these uh CH they're called the Chicago
boys which is pejorative um and so they
want to do you know sort of neoclassical
economics foreign policy free markets
free prices you know open trade they
really get nowhere um eventually it's in
I think it's in
1973 that um Salvador aende who's a
socialist mark is elected and then 3
years later I might be getting my exact
dates wrong I think it's 70 70 7 70 he's
elected 73 he's overthrown by um Pinos
in a military coup it's it's bloody it's
violent um and there's just a a great
deal of up during the alende regime and
afterwards and so when um Pinos comes
into Power the inflation rate in Chile
is 600% a year um so it's a it's a sort
of macroeconomic Crisis and a political
crisis is wrapped in one and then um a
year in they've gotten the inflation
down about 300% but he's still having a
lot of problems and it's at that point
that the Chicago boys really been
offstage for most of us are able to come
and get into the regime and say look we
have a wholly different way to do this
we have a different set of approaches
let's do that and as as they're getting
you know this policy considered they
basically call Freeman and they say can
you come and can you talk about um what
we should do to like how we should
manage economy how we can address
inflation so Freeman decides to come he
spends six days in the country he meets
a lot of um you know s of members of the
Chilean State he meets Pinos he tells
him you should tackle inflation you have
to do basically a shock treatment you
have such bad inflation you can't wait
you can't be a gradualist he's a
gradualist in the United States but not
in this hyperinflation situation so then
um any also tells pince if you open the
economy the way you will you want to
eventually you're going to have to
liberalize um and from the accounts we
have Pinos is basically like isn't this
going to cause too much Social pain and
disruption and Freeman says you kind of
have no choice and that's the message he
gives to the country more broadly and so
I have I found a travelog where he
writes all his like he the few days
after he got back from Chile he wrote
all this down so I have a really good
sense of what his Impressions were we
can't be exactly sure of what he said
because it's is censored press but most
of his talks were like pretty boring
like um you know monetary policy at any
rate that is the policy that's put in
place um and so fredman really puts his
kind of emeter on the market-based
reforms and he doesn't view this as
advising you know a politician with whom
he's aligned it's it's not as if he
agreed to be on the Council of economic
advisers of Pinos because he supports
his plan you know he's done it's it's
the context is American economists
flying around the world telling
socialist countries like become more
capitalists right pretty common uh
common move and so then he leaves and a
couple it's it's not too long after that
one of Pen's leading opponents who's in
Exile in the United States is
assassinated by P by P you know this
they have this kind of secret police and
in a car bomb on the streets of
Washington DC it's completely shocking
then just a couple weeks later Freedman
gets awarded the Nobel and the man who
was assassinated was quite critical of
fredman and and interpreted fredman as a
supporter of pinoe and even thought he
was part of the kind of architect of the
coup so then he's assassinated then the
Nobel Prize happen so the result is just
this all gets mixed together and it
comes to seem as if the Nobel Prize
committee and the sort of industrialized
West has decided to approve and endorse
the Pinos regime and and so that's
really a framing that's put on it um by
uh you know Chilean Exiles um and who
are very angry with Freeman and feel
like he should just have steered clear
of the country entirely so it becomes um
just a real it's a real controversy it's
very painful for Freeman and over time
he'll realize he has to speak out more
forcefully about political Freedom you
know his remarks previous to that are
really all about economic freedom and
eventually he kind of realized I have to
talk about political Freedom too so
you'll see a shift um one more thing I
would say that you and I chatted about
briefly offline is that you know
Freedman doesn't come out in support of
the regime but there are some other um
uh you know economists most notably fa
Hayek who offer more justifications and
defenses of the regime and I think in
the kind of public memory Freeman gets
kind of lumped into that um and so it's
all seen as this endorsement of a
military government and Freeman's really
horrified he's like I I didn't ever
perceive that going there to give my
advice you know I'm the world expert on
inflation there's 300% hyperinflation
like of course I'm going to go and say
here's what I think should be done that
doesn't mean I support pinoe so he's
it's a it's a it's a difficult period
for him why do you think that um slag
against him has you know been so long
liveed though some of it I just think is
misinformation you know there's there's
a belief that the the coup was done in
the service of this particular set of
economic ideas um and so that's kind of
like Naomi Klein's uh in her shock
Doctrine book yeah there's some do
documentaries where it's seen that like
this was all sort of part of a master
plan and that um it was necessary to you
know people were so committed to
capitalism that they needed an
autocratic government to sort of force
it on the country so um I mean it's it's
sort of an inverse Narrative of the
connection between socialism and you
know authoritarian regimes and so I
think it has some Powers being an
inversion of that um so I guess my hope
is that with more information on what
happened we can have sort of like a
better understanding of it and is that
kind of that connection is that the
origin of when fredman really started to
talk about how when you get economic
freedom political Freedom comes traving
long yeah I think so what happened was
then so this is like 75 he goes to Chile
76 is the Nobel Prize and then the Mont
pin Society has its meeting I think it's
a regional meeting in like 1981 which
again
is interpreted as like this is an
endorsement and Freeman's really worried
about that and he actually gets some
there was a an economist who was in the
government and he gets him disinvited to
the meeting because he doesn't want to
feel like there's a connection and at
this meeting Chileans are starting to
say um mimic the leftist line that like
we only got capitalism because we had a
strong government and like we needed
that strong government to get capitalism
and freedman's like no no no no no no no
no this is not how it works and he
starts kind of pushing back more um I
think he's also trying to push back
against Hayek and then talk more and I
think you know for most of his career
he's in American Academia and he's
taking political freedom for granted and
he's thinking my peers need to focus
more on economic freedom and then he
gets out into the world and it's like oh
you know maybe I need to be talking
about political Freedom first because
these two are intertwined let's have
some questions sir your question make it
a question if we will have a withering
glare I I'm a I'm an economic journalist
who had about 20 conversations with
Milton fedman over the years and you're
going to tell us about each one
including a mon yes including including
a month before he died and uh I may well
quote you in the book have to look at
the foot notes the uh the question I had
a debate with I had a recent debate with
David fredman and that point you make
about David and his family is just
hilarious I embarrassed him a bit about
that but uh that aside I loved your book
because I loved Milton fredman but of
course given my intimate knowledge of
this guy by the way if you called him up
there was no answering machine it would
just ring for 20 times
uh question I'll get to my question but
then also also I want to bunch to your
point I think you do make the point
because because screw Nick I think you
do make the point that that Milton
Freeman also advised the Chinese and
nobody holds him responsible for the
authority and he also talked to Tito in
Yugoslavia yeah yeah so he talks to
people and they don't blame him for that
but that aside I I do want to go at you
for uh that classic point the one thing
when Milton fedman insulted me the most
was when he started to talk about the
drug laws and I and actually I think it
might I'm best of my recollection you
don't mention that when he got started
on the drug laws in my 20 conversation
with boy would he he wanted a complete
abolition of the drug law and of course
his famous statement was that look my
fundamental objection is that the
government has no more right to tell me
what I put in my mouth as it tells me to
to to what comes out of my mouth and and
you yourself have said and he also said
of course that a government that that
that pushes Freedom will get more
equality as well and then on top of that
you've just reminded me that that he not
only wanted school choice he really
wanted the government out of school
would you like me to comment on the drug
legalization you know I I'm not sure
that he would but why let's talk about
the drug the role of the drug war you
just made the point that he also wanted
to schools out of schooling the
government out of schooling allog
together so that's why we Libertarians
and then you yourself said he wanted a
roll back of about 60% of government
expenditures a lot of people would say
that's very Liber so do you want to roll
that up into a single question yes why
didn't you call the book The subtitle
one of the great nights of
libertarianism
yeah you know what uh I'll take that
under consideration for the sequel thank
you
um would you uh talk a little bit about
the uh drug laws yeah I mean I think the
the commenter has summed up how that is
really part of fredman's worldview and
that freedom and kind of liberationist
ethos um yeah so I think he he very much
saw that as part of and again I think
also Buckley also supported legalization
you know to some degree squishy I I
don't I don't know what Freeman would
make if you walked him down the streets
in San Francisco and said this is what
it actually looks like like I mean he
tended to stick to his principles
through thick and thin so maybe he would
stick with it but I think we just saw
Oregon Portlandia starting to take a
step back from that when they see what
it looks like did um maybe as a followup
did uh fredman how would you um talk
about his change over time because did
he he became he never became an
anarchist his son David fredman is in a
narco capitalist or help popularize that
um did he become more of uh more
libertarian or more of a minimal
government yeah I think he did and I
think some of that is evolution and some
of that is changing context so I think
the Nicks Administration was really a
watershed moment for him because he saw
how much the state grew under Republican
and it also coincided with his
discovering of public choice and kind of
really buying into that and I think he
concluded look the dynamic of government
is growth it just grows and so therefore
I've got to push back harder than I
thought in order to restrain it and so I
think you know maybe if there had if the
government hadn't grown as much as it
did over the the federal state over the
course of the 20th century he wouldn't
have shifted but he really did shift so
he becomes much more anti-government as
he comes into just gets sharper you know
that kind of early Chicago ethos Fades a
bit I think it's part of its
popularization you know and he's in fre
choose he has to really simplify you
know so you get the monetary history as
like the government caused a Great
Depression which it's not really what
the monetary history is really saying in
the round but then what I hadn't
expected is in the last like five or so
years of his life he gets reflective and
he talks about a lot of the things he
got wrong and so so even though he gets
a little bit more he it's almost like he
gets a little bit more rigid and then he
kind of relaxes and opens up a little
bit in the last years of his life all
right next question thanks I was curious
about fredman's kind of engagements with
people on other parts of the right to
him so you mentioned the conservative
tradition whether he read people like
Russell Kirk or you know so that on the
one side and then more radical
Libertarians than him right the Free
banking folks and so on so two part
question good question so the first
letter he ever wrote to William F
Buckley was is co-signed with Aaron
director and they were criticizing an
article by Russell Kirk that in turn
criticized The Mont Pellerin society and
and fredman kind of said young man you
know kind of wagged his finger at bu
Russell Kirk was never a young man no
Buckley was the young man who had given
him the given him the the platform so um
so he didn't he tended sort of like he
avoided talking about the Vietnam War he
tended to avoid the kind of Social and
religious issues and as they rose up
into prominence he really didn't comment
much about them you know he he knew what
he wanted to to focus on in terms of the
anarco capitalist I mean I think David
was a real connection to that community
and I think he would say he might have
said something like I wish I could be an
anarchist but I don't I can't go all you
know he just sort of fundamentally
thought it wasn't um practical I I
imagine as a you know a Jewish man
growing up in the 20th century he feared
Anarchy a bit as well and finally on the
banking I mean if you look at the
Chicago teaching it's like the state and
money are just they're intrinsically
tied and fredman thought even if you let
a thousand flowers bloom and had all
these competing currencies eventually
people would Converge on one and you
would basically recreate State money so
thank you could you very quickly uh what
was his relationship with Ein Rand like
oh yeah um well Ein Rand called him a
communist to be fair that's kind of how
she said hello
yes and you know his quote on her was um
a very unpleasant woman who did a great
deal of good I think um and so there was
a moment when the objectivist kind of
took over the new individualist review
which was headquartered at Chicago and
they started like heckling him and
really making life he was like what is
happening then he figured out oh these
are randians so um again he tried to
just appreciate her as someone who would
get people interested in these ideas but
I mean they were very different people
yeah uh next question please so
following up on that last question there
there were there are also uh some
macroeconomic schools of conservative
thought that differ from fredman uh but
are very influential and concurrent with
them for instance the supply Siders you
know arguing about the centrality of
good supply side tax policy and then you
have the free traders who argue that for
instance the smooth Holly Tariff was the
real cause of the Great Depression and
explains why it was a worldwide
phenomenon and how those tariff Wars
caused everything so how did how did
fredman interact with those other macro
theories uh that were extremely
influential and all you know came
together in Reaganomics but he was only
onethird of that piie but what do you
think of those other two-thirds that
were so influential yeah that's an
excellent question so with supply side
he was suspicious of it and there's some
early arguments where he's like you know
sure there so and this is specifically
the supply side idea that um if you
lower tax rates you will get more tax
revenue because the lowering of tax
rates will stimulate the economy and he
said sure that will be the case in some
cases I don't think it will work
systemwide but I support it anyhow
because lowering tax revenue will uh the
governor the government won't be able to
do as much so he really makes this like
strategic endorsement of supply supp
side when it comes to taxation um he
doesn't he he's not a believer in going
back to the gold standard and and to the
extent that that's part of supply side
he won't even have the conversation he
the austrians he doesn't like that
either he's he's always in a running
debate with other Libertarians who want
to go back to gold from the like 1940s
on and he will never he he really
doesn't count and I said all the way to
Schwarz basically you know putting in
the same kind of the nail and the often
in the gold Commission in 1982 he also
believed uh he was fond of saying that
the ultimate measure of the state was
how much it spent he seemed to believe
that governments would not deficit spend
um and he you know starting with Reagan
at the very least seemed to be way off
on that yeah I mean so the same place
where he endorses supply side um there's
another you know he says well the the
Reagan Administration of course will be
fiscally respons responsible and then he
argues you know deficits aren't bad
unless they're inflated away and they
won't do that and also the deficit won't
get that bad because they'll be
responsible so so he's part of that
shift to legitimating deficits and in
part that's because he sort of hasn't
seen anything yet he thinks the spending
is going to be restrained and then
eventually by the 80s like he's a team
player you know and so he's not he's not
going to waste a lot of time on Friendly
Fire you know he's going to he's going
to try to minime differences and
accentuate um agreement uh next question
please um could you talk a little bit
about the impact that freedan had on
Asia and in particular his relationship
with Hong Kong where I'm from and is it
true this is what I heard this was refer
in Hong Kong that our move away from
free markets is what killed him is that
true uh great that's a conspiracy theory
I could do something with I'm pretty
sure that he died of natural causes at
94 is so he did he he admired and was
really interested in Hong Kong as kind
of a laboratory of of capitalism um he
was very optimistic on China he went
several I think he went in the 50s he
went in the 70s he went in the 80s and
when he saw tianan Square he thought
this is the beginning of the end this is
that D of the Chinese regime of the
Chinese that the Chinese regime has
liberalized its economy and eventually
The Dominoes will fall and it will have
to liberalize its Society so he said
eventually there'll be more chanam men's
and and again he has this great object
lesson in Chile because in 1980 Chile is
a pleite to go back to democracy and
they transition to democracy around 1989
so he's seen an example of it he thinks
it will work um and yeah he was not
right about that yet um and in general
when he started looking more at Asian
econom IC development in the later part
of his life that's when he started
talking about so he's always talked
about political Freedom economic freedom
he starts talking about Civic freedom
and I think this is inspired by
Singapore maybe to some degree Hong Kong
this idea that you could um meet you
could have meetings maybe even a little
bit of a protest but you didn't have
Democratic choice and that to him was
Civic freedom and so he was trying to
find he was trying to identify another
type of regime in which wasn't the
wasn't like a secret police or a
repressive State apparatus but you
didn't have Democratic choice you had
limited freedoms and you had economic
freedom you kind of trying to figure out
how that all fit together but again he's
made a couple trips to these countries
and he's trying to kind of fit them in
his schema he didn't have any
particularly deep knowledge of that
region of the world next question yes so
I think uh as successful as Freedman was
in an academic context writing all the
journal articles writing uh coming up
with his theory of inflation history of
monetary History of the United States I
think what sets him apart in a lot of
ways is his ability to communicate these
ideas to a broader audience to people
who are less economically literate
things like capitalism and freedom or um
free to choose the TV series right so
what made him so unique in his ability
to do this and what are some of the
lessons we can learn today when trying
to communicate some of those same ideas
um excellent question my onew answer is
Rose and so find find a good a good
partner but I do I I say that in just
but the the books of his so for monetary
history really transcended just
economics and also so did free to choose
and um capitalism and freedom they they
both had they all had women co-authors
and I think what that did was it
wouldn't necessarily have to happen
because they were women but they had a
different intellectual orientation so
Schwarz was more of a historian
interested in narrative kind of
grounding these really abstract ideas in
stories that people could relate to and
likewise Rose would help him work out
his Newsweek columns and then she would
kind of prime him off stage before he
got in front of the camera and talked so
I think he he wasn't just an economist
and he wasn't just immersed in other
people who were they were professional
economists but they had brought other
intellectual skills so I think it's
something about that and I also do think
like his and narrative and story are
just really this how humans communicate
and share ideas and those can't be
forgotten it's uh really fascinating the
discussion of how he how he worked on
free to choose where he he had some
notes but you know like Jackie gleon he
didn't like to rehearse but but Rose
would kind of put him through his Paces
correct up a little bit and she did that
with his Newsweek column yeah and and
apparently he really wasn't sure about
doing the Newsweek column you know he's
busy right and so apparently she and
David like tag teamed him for like 48
hours and were like you got to do this
um so he had he had a support team I
mean that's another big lesson is one
reason he achieved so much is that he
had a lot of other people helping him
intellectually behind the scenes and
then he also plugged into all these
networks you which I describe in the
book we haven't really touched on here
but he had lifelong friends that were
also committed to the same causes as he
was so and he was pretty generous and uh
you know he he didn't pretend that he
was a universal genius work yeah he was
like the anti- Rand in that he he gave a
lot of credit to other people yes
compared to Rand he was quite generous
yeah which is the most scathing
indictment of a human you could say
right but okay um just before my
question I needed to point out that
fredman did in multiple places advocate
for abolishing the Federal Reserve and
even in 1984 he writes a paper where
he sketches a proposal for phasing out
the Federal Reserve and
allowing Free banking to take its place
so he did even go that far at at some
point in his career later part my
question is that um throughout his
career he advocated for the idea
especially in the late 70s and onward of
a constitutional amendment to limit
total government spending and it even
went somewhere in the 1980s when the
Reagan Administration the Republicans
tried to get it passed in Congress uh so
could you talk about his efforts there
to yeah for sure um yeah and just on the
on the first point is interesting in the
beginning when he would appear before
Congress he would still tout 100% money
you know this is in the early 60s and
then eventually over time he's like well
you should have a monetary growth rule
you know and so I think he he kind of
realized if you show up to Congress and
say rip up your banking system Roo and
branch no one's going to listen to you
but if you say well here's my kind of
technical tweak then you then you get
somewhere um so the second part of the
question was about about sorry refresh
my memory about the Constitutional
amendment to limit overall government
expenditure I mean I think this is where
he this is what he took from public
Choice Theory and whether it was an
actual Constitution or just another kind
of rules-based framework so um such as
many states passed which would either be
like a balanced budget amendment or a
super majority for um a tax raise or
setting like capping property taxes that
was very promising to him cuz it goes
back to rules over discretion you set up
a new rule and a structure and then the
politician can't change it or it's more
difficult for them to change it so
instead of kind of lobbying and being
trying to influence the decision makers
you kind of change the the setting in
which decisions are made so I would say
he he was involved in these state level
organizations it's actually what he was
doing when he um won the Nobel Prize I
think he was in Michigan and the
Michigan organizers really had Freeman
out and they're like God this is going
so great like look at all the media here
like our cause is really great and then
they're like oh Freeman won the Nobel
Prize like that's why they're all here
so that was very important to him for
sure next
question this was alluded to a bit
earlier a couple of times but uh to how
well did uh Hayak and the distinctly
anti-positivist austrians get along with
the monitor school fredman and the
entire Chicago School
yeah I think there was a lot of mutual
suspicion but also a lot of effort to
kind of bury the hatchet um so you know
hyek is really pushing back while he's
at Chicago and it's hard because while
they're together and interacting the
most you don't have the most you can't
really see into that relationship but um
Hayek thought any type of monetary
growth rule was simp was inflation
simply put so he's very suspicious of
that and then um so he's kind of you
know he's kind of always at them as they
kind of reformulating monetarism in the
1950s then later you know he's really
emerging as the trying to be the
opposite of fredman in terms of like in
Britain we should do more of a shock
treatment versus gradualism um and so I
think there's tension there and I think
Hayek regretted maybe not um there's a
couple places where he's like I wish I
had like discredited fredman or I wish I
had pushed back against fredman more but
at the same time they do perceive
themselves as being in some sort of
Alliance and so they're better than some
other political movements at kind of
keeping those disagreements more quiet
rather than they're both very I mean
very clearly and broadly liberal in uh
19th and early 20th century since yeah
so they're they're on the same side
pushing back against things like Central
planning and all of that kind of stuff
and I think yeah but the the money is a
a point of difference like how they
would manage with it's the gold standard
or banking or Free banking they never
quite come together on that but again
you know Hayek Hayek goes to many
different stages you have to kind of
figure out which Hayek is the one we're
we're talking about I like Salma
hyek no and there is a real distinction
between the positivism and the the kind
of Austrian understanding which really
approximates postmodernism we won't go
into that thank you next and final
question um it seems like similar to
Chile uh of students uh from Chicago um
came to Brazil to lead part of the
monetary Revolution um combating
hyperinflation but um from what I
understand it seemed like Freedman was
not very um a big fan of the plan itself
and it felt like it wasn't going far
enough because there was still a big
fiscal deficit in Brazil and I guess
from what I understood um his position
on the IMF saw that IMF was subsidizing
a lot of the fiscal deficits around the
globe including Brazil so I was just
wondering what was your uh if if you
could give us any more caller on his uh
position on the IMF and his involvement
or his students involvement in the
monetary revolution in Brazil yeah
that's a great question I wish I could
say more about Brazil but I cannot um
but I do know that he and George Schultz
called for the abolition of IMF and the
World Bank and um they for this reason
that you sort of mentioned they thought
it created these moral hazard or kind of
perverse incentives that was easy to
spend other people's money and that they
basically had kind of Juiced the
development process beyond what it could
sustain um and they also so this this
became for fredman sort of emblematic of
how when I talked about his belief that
the dynamic of government is growth that
once an organization or a bureaucracy is
created it just finds a way to sustain
itself and he saw these as created
during the time of Breton Woods to kind
of sustain the Breton Woods monetary
system
and then Bret and woods ended and they
kind of reinvented themselves to sort of
global development agencies and he
thought this was really problematic and
they should just be um they should just
be abolished so he and George Schultz
who had been the secretary treasury so
they had the kind of like a bunch of
co-author a couple op-eds didn't really
go anywhere but it's interesting because
it has this sort of echo with the
anti-wto movements you know so you have
that kind
of left left right Synergy horseshoe a
good horseshoe the yeah potential
horseshoe and he was friendly with
Schultz they were both on the faculty at
Chicago yeah and that's a relationship I
talk about when the relationship with
Arthur Burns collapses he and George
Schultz become extremely close and
that's one of the ways Freeman proves so
influential in the Nixon Administration
is through the kind of the evolution of
Brett and woods or the last days of
Breton woods and really Schultz is kind
of his man on the inside do you think
that Milton Freeman would would have
invested or lent his credibility to
Theos like Geor Schultz did did he have
any big you know stupid Investments uh
you know actually I apparent I I don't I
did not find they did not put their like
balance sheet in the archive so I don't
know and that's really rose right I mean
she talked she was paying all the bills
right she was writing all the checks I
mean they ended up having a pretty nice
life so I think they made some good
Investments but they also got in early
and just stayed in and it was the
American Century you know I guess as a
final question um what do you think
Freedman would have made of Javier Malay
in Argentina I think named one of his
clone dogs after Milton Freedman yeah I
think he'd be really really excited um I
mean I think he would so irran would not
be able to set aside the parts of Malay
that are more socially conservative um
and uh I think fredman might notice the
populism but I think would focus more on
theide idea that this is a really
straightforward cure for the ills that
Argentina has been suffering for you
know for so long and so I think he would
say if he does it right it's going to
have a trajectory like Chile you know in
terms of developing a really strong
economy so I think he'd be very excited
and I think yeah I mean mle sounds like
he's in a Chicago economic seminar when
he lays out you know his his ideas so I
think he'd be thrilled yeah Robert Lucas
is one of his dogs as well I think it's
like it might be mis's ro ro
Freeman and Lucas I don't know about
yeah Freeman and Lucas a little
different I always thought that
Libertarians like cats more than dogs
but I I guess not right um I want to
thank Jennifer Burns for talking to
reason uh the book the book is Milton
fredman the last conservative thank you
so much for talking thanks for having me
thanks for coming
[Music]
out
a